une décharge que l'on devine à peine
loin mais à mobilise une poignée de
militants très inquiet ils ont organisé
une conférence de presse pour alerter
les autorités publiques
selon eux cette décharge située à 1,5 km
du village de thé sous montfort n'a rien
de banal
sa particularité c'est que c'est qu'elle
est situé sur la parcelle 49 du cadastre
de thé sous montfort et que selon nos
informations cette parcelle 49
appartient à un agriculteur de tel qui
est conventionné par la filiale de
nestlé agrivert agrivert est censée
protéger les ressources en eau et
perçoit des aides financières de l'état
et de l'europe
l'association anticor se demande
pourquoi gris vert n'a pas demandé à
l'agriculteur propriétaire du terrain
sur lequel se trouve la décharge de
retirer les gravats selon l'association
de lutte contre la corruption
l'argent public cette filiale de nestlé
perçoit l'obligent à agir d'autant plus
que selon ces militants l'eau des nappes
phréatiques exploité par nestlé pourrait
bien être menacé
on voit qu'il ya du goudron on voit
qu'elle du béton donc on peut se poser
des questions s'il n'ya pas aussi de
l'amiante tout simplement le terrain sur
lequel se trouve la décharge est situé
sur une pente selon les militants avec
les pluies
il y à un risque de contamination des
nappes phréatiques exploité par nestlé
pour produire ces bouteilles d'eau
potentiellement les nappes qui qu'on
appelle les gîtes hydro minérales du
letten cole qui sert en fait à prélever
par l'esl et lalo et par et bien
potentiellement ces cinq forages qui
sont situées entre eux tu es le village
de réville peuvent être contaminés par
des polluants qui serait dans ce numéro
9 les militants ont décidé de faire un
signalement pour faire la lumière sur
cette décharge vieille de cinq ans il
espère qu'elle finira par disparaître
ils ont écrit au maire de thé sous
montfort pour lui demander d'agir
agly vert et la mairie n'ont pas donné
suite à nos demandes de contact